اهلا بكم من هو الارهابي ومن يحدد هويته
يطرح السؤال منذ مده ليست بالقصيره
والاجابات عليه ليست محل اجماع على
الاطلاق بل ان من تعتبرهم دول معينه
ارهابيين يعدون مناضلين ومطالبين بحق
بلدانهم في التحرر وتبعا لاختلاف المعايير
تختلف قوائم الارهاب والدول والكيانات
التي تمارسه او ترعاها غير ان اصحاب قوائم
الارهاب انفسهم لا يتقيدون بالضروره بما
يترتب على تلك التصنيفات تقرير محمد
ابراهيم الارهاب ومن هم الارهابيون سؤال
عريض مازال يبحث عن اجابه مظهر المصطلح
قبل عقود ولا سما بعد انتشاره على نطاق
واسع في الولايات المتحده عقب احداث
الحادي عش بال
سبتمبر بسبب الخلافات حول المساله لم تفلح
الامم المتحده حتى اليوم في اصدار تعريف
محدد له ولم تتفق دول العالم على اليه
مشتركه بعد لتصنيف الجماعات الارهابيه
تاثرت وجهات النظر بين الدول بالمصالح
الوطنيه والقوميه والاعتبارات السياسيه
لكل منها على حداء لم تكن الولايات
المتحده بعيده عن تلك الاعتبارات بل كانت
الاشهر فيما عرف باللوائح السوداء او
قوائم الارهاب تلك الخاصه بالجماعات
والمنظمات او ما تسمى قائمه الدول الراعيه
للارهاب لكن ما هو معيار التصنيف الامريكي
وكيف تدير واشنطن هذه المساله ويسير على
هداها كثير من دول العالم كان القانون
المحلي الامريكي اصبح قانونا
دوليا كان هؤلاء في جبال افغانستان
يعتبرون حركه تحرر وطنيه ضد الغزو
السوفيتي دعمتهم واشنطن اواخر السبعينات
وهاهم ذاتهم اليوم من خرجت من صفوفهم
القاعده وافراد اصبحوا على قوائم الارهاب
الامريكيه وباتوا العدو الاشر الذي تحاربه
في كل مكان اخيرهم وربما ليس اخرهم تنظيم
الدوله في العراق
والشام تحدث تلك القائمه تبعا للتطورات
والتغييرات السياسيه وتخضع للتعديل من حين
لاخر اما حذفا لاسماء ودول او ادراج لاخرى
جديده وبات ابرز ما يحكمها وفق المحللين
معايير سياسيه صرفه المفارقه ان تنظيمات
تجاهر باعمال توصف بالارهابي وتمارس جميع
انواع التطرف قتلا وتعذيب وحرقا للبشر
ليست على قوائم الارهاب بل تغطي واشنطن
عملياتها العسكريه هنا في العراق يقاتل
المارز جنبا الى جنب مع منظمه بدر وعصائب
باهل الحق وكتائب حزب الله ولواء ابي
الفضل العباس وعشرات الفصائل المنضوي تحت
لواء ميليشيا الحشد الشعبي التي اشتهرت
على نطاق واسع بارتكاب الجرائم ضد
الانسانيه وعلى مراى ومسمع التحالف الدولي
وقيادته الامريكيه حزب العمال الكردستاني
اسم بارز على القوائم الامريكيه السوداء
لكن احد اذرعه في سوريا تقدمه واشنطن على
انه يدها الطوله في محاربه الارهاب
بالمنطقه الوحدات الكرديه الفرع السوري
لحزب العمال الكردستاني الموضوعي ايضا على
قوا دول اوروبيه في تصنيفاتها للمنظمات
الارهابيه باتت تزود بمدرعات واسلحه ثقيله
وتقام معها غرف عمليات مشتركه على الارض
فضلا عن التغطيه الجويه وتغض واشنطن ودول
غربيه الطرف عما تمارسه من قتل وتهجير
للمدنيين هي نماذج من قوائم الولايات
المتحده السوداء وتصنيفاتها التي ادرجت
ضمنها حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس وحركه
تحرر وطنيه في دول اسلاميه رغم ت رض ذلك
مع ميثاق الامم المتحده الذي يكفل حق
الشعوب في النضال والتحرر وهكذا اضحى
مصطلح الارهاب يجوب العالم وهو اشبه بقبعه
توضع على راس هذا وتنزع عن راس ذاك لعلها
الحقيقه الوحيده التي يتفق عليها الجميع
وخاصه قوائم واشنطن المعنيه بتصنيف
الارهاب لمناقشات الموضوع ينضم الينا من
لندن الدكتور محمد قواس الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ومن واشنطن الدكتور جيمز كفانو
مدير معهد الدراسات الدوليه في مؤسسه
هريتج اهلا بكما دكتور قواس لماذا لم
تستطع حتى الان الدول العظمى والامم
المتحده بتوحيد تعريف الارهاب
بتقديرك طبعا الارهاب هو استخدام العنف
لاغراض سياسيه ويختلف عن استخدام العنف
لاغراض جنائيه وبالتالي طالما الارهاب هو
مفهوم سياسي تعريف الارهاب يختلف ما بين
دوله واخرى ما بين تيار سياسي واخر
وبالتالي ايضا هذه الدول المجتمعه في في
داخل الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده هي دول
تختلف على كل شيء تختلف في الثقافه وفي
التقليد وفي المناخ الايديولوجي والسياسي
وهي غير مضطره حتى الان الى ان تجد تعريفا
واحدا يوحد ما هو الارهاب ما بين هل تب لك
عفوا دكتور انها تميز بين هذه الصغيره
التي
ذكرتها تماما الارهاب طبعا هو اداه من
ادوات السياسه
ويستخدم لصالح هذه الدوله او تلك كما كما
يعني اشرتم في التقرير المقاومون في
افغانستان كانوا مقاومين وتحولوا ذ بعد
ذلك الى الى ارهابيين وفقا لوظيفه هذا
العمل السياسي العنيف ام لا لكن ذلك ليس
غريبا ايضا طالما انه الارهاب هو عمل
سياسي ويخضع ايضا لمزاج سياسي
ولتبدأ
رغم يعني ما ما يعتليها من شوائب هناك كثر
يقولون بان تعريف الارهاب في هذه القائمه
متناقض رغم هذا تهيمن على غيرها من
التعريفات في العالم لماذا
برايك يمكن القول ان هناك الكثير من
التلاقي في وجهات النظر حول ما هو مقصود
بالارهاب فالار يعني قتل الابرياء لتحقيق
مكاسب سياسيه وكثير من الحكومات تتفق على
ذلك اذا فكره ان نقول انه لا يوجد اتفاق
على مفهوم الارهاب ليس صحيحا رغم ان هناك
بالتاكيد مؤثرات سياسيه لكن الفروقات على
الاعم الاغلب هي قانونيه
وطبعا بلدان الع ومنظومات والتكتلات لها
انظمه قانونيه مختلفه حتى الاتحاد
الاوروبي دوله لها انظمه قانونيه وقضائيه
خاصه بكل واحده منها ومن ثم فان هناك
اختلافات طبعا الكل
ي اسمحلي انا ساذكر لك اختلافات في
القائمه الامريكيه مثلا امريكا تعتبر حزب
العمال الكردستاني منظمه ارهابيه بينما
قوات الجيش الامريكي تقاتل جنبا الى جنب
بوحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه والتي تعتبر
ذراع من حمايه او ذراع من حزب العمال
الكردستاني كما ذكر الدكتور
قواس القتال في افغانستان اعتبر جهادا
بينما القتال في فلسطين المحتله من قبل
حماس يعتبر ارهابا لماذا هذا التناقض حماس
لم
تطلق رصاصه واحده خارج فلسطين
المحتله
اذا لنعد اولا الى سؤالك وهو لماذا لا
تتفق كل بلدان العالم في تعاملها مع
الارهاب طبعا الولايات المتحده لا تستطيع
فرض ذلك على العالم لان كل بلد له نظامه
القانوني
والجرائم تحكم من قبل انظمه القضائيه اذا
لا تستطيع الولايات المتحده ان تفرض ارها
تعريفا للها
السؤال ولا له حقيقه اذا ما طرحناه دكتور
قواص التفلت الغربي بوضع قوائم ارهاب
وتعريف الارهاب هل هو برايك ما سمح لدول
مثل دول الحصار مثلا ان تضع قائمه خاصه
بها لكيانات وافراد تعتبرهم
ارهابيين اولا مساله اعتبار
جماعات معينه هي جماعات ارهابيه هي من حق
اي نظام سياسي ومن حق اي دوله ان تعتبر ان
هذه الجماعات ارهابيه بينما الجاره الدوله
الجاره او اي دوله اخرى لا تعتبر انه هذه
الجماعات ارهابيه وهذا يعود ايضا الى
الخلاف بالرؤى السياسيه بين هذه الدوله او
تلك لاحظ معي ايضا ان هناك لائحه امريكيه
لجماعات ارهابيه لا تنطبق مع اللائحه
الموجوده في اوروبا علما ان
اوروبا والولايات المتحده هما جزء واحد من
المنظومه الغربيه وبالتالي ايضا يجب
الاعتراف انه طالما هنا هناك اختلاف في
الرؤى السياسيه هناك اختلاف في تعريف هذا
الارهاب ومن هي هذه الجماعات الارهابيه
هذه الدوله عندما ا عندما تكون صديقه
لدوله اخرى تعتبر انه من يعتدي على الدوله
الاخرى هو ارهابي وبالتالي اي منطق اخر لا
يمكن ان يكون موضوعيا او محيدا في هذا
الشان هذا تماما وجهه نظر الولايات
المتحده فيها في ان تعتبر كل فصيل يقوم
بعمليه في اسرائيل هو ارهابي لانه تعتبر
انه اسرائيل صديق ولا تعتبر نفس هذا
الفصيل في منطقه اخرى ارهابيا مثالك حول
حزب العمال الكردستاني صارخ في هذا المجال
حزب العمال الكردستاني هو حزب ارهابي على
اللوائح الاوروبيه والامريكيه لكن توابعه
في سوريا ليست كذلك لانه المصلحه المصلحه
الامريكيه المصلحه الاوروبيه بغض النظر عن
تقييمنا لهذه المصلحه ليست كذلك الامر
ليس يعني ليس غامضا هو واضح جدا طالما
مصالحنا لا تتناقض مع هذه الجماعات فلن
تعتبر ارهابا دكتور كفانو الى اي مدى نريد
ان نفهم اكثر التفكير الامريكي الى اي مدى
تدخل السياسه والحسابات السياسيه في وضع
هذه اللوائح فيما يتعلق
بالارهاب اعتقد ان السياسه تلعب دورا مهما
ساضرب لكم مثلا هنا الولايات المتحده
اعتبرت كوريا الشماليه راعيه للارهاب ثم
ازالتها من القائمه وكان ذلك قرارا سياسيا
الى حد كبير لانهم كانوا
يريدون التفاوض معها وكبابه حسنيه رفعوا
اسمها من قائمه الدول الراعي للارهاب لكن
فيما يتعلق بفهم الق انا اختلف مع الضيف
الاخر هنا اقول
ان الساسه الامريكيون
محكومون بالقانون الامريكي وفيما يتعلق
برفع اسم كوريا الشماليه رغم الاختلاف
القانوني ورغم استحقاق كوريا الشمالي لذلك
لكن الاعتبارات
السياسيه طبعا في النهايه ايضا هناك جانب
قانوني وهناك جانب استخباراتي في القضيه
في كثير من الحالات عليك ان تمتلك
المعلومات لكي تقرر نعم في افغانستان كنا
ندعم المجاهدين وايضا كانت هناك مجموعات
ارهابيه تدعم المجاهدين لكن لكن ال
المتحده لم تعتبر القاعده كمجموعه مدافعه
عن الحريه بشكل شرعي دكتور قواس اذا اخذنا
الاخوان المسلمون مثلا هم لم يدرجوا على
ولا اي قائمه غربيه
في لائحه الارهاب بينما دول عربيه تضعهم
على لائحه الارهاب ما مدى وجاهه هذا الطرح
بتقديرك خصوصا ان يعني لاحظنا ان الامم
المتحده رفضت اي قائمه خارج القائمه التي
وضعتها
هي طيب الامم المتحده هي تضع قوائمها لكن
ايضا من وجهه نظر اي دوله ان تضع اي قائمه
تراها ارهابيه هذه وجهه نظر هذا ليس ليس
ميزان علمي اذا كانت بعض الدول العربيه
اعتبر انه جماعات الاخوان المسلمين هي
جماعات ارهابيه فهذا من حقها ومن حق دول
اخرى ان تضحد ذلك او تدافع عن موقف مضاد
لكن بكل الاحوال هذه ولكن هذا لا يلزم
الدول الاخرى بان تعتبر ايضا ان ان ان هذه
المجموعه الارهابيه كما يحدث مثلا مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كما ذكرت هناك
هيمنه امريكيه فبالتالي كل الدول تعتبر من
تعتبره امريكا ارهابيا تعتبره ارهابيا
صحيح ليس بالضروره ذلك ابدا الولايات
المتحده لديها لا لائحه يعني لاحظ معي
انها تضع حزب الله على لائحه الارهاب لكن
اوروبا تضع الجناح العسكري لحزب الله على
على لائحه الارهاب هم يحاولون ايجاد تميز
معين في الدول العربيه هناك من يعتبر ان
هناك جماعات ارهابيه وهناك جماع وهناك
بلدان اخرى عربيه لا تعترف بان هذه
الجماعات ارهابيه هذه لها علاقه بوجهه نظر
اذا ما تم الاتفاق بين الاطراف المتناقضه
حتى اليوم في الازمه الخليجيه اذا ما تم
الاتفاق وتوصلت هذه الدول الى تسويه معينه
فهم سيتفقون ايضا على مفهوم واحد لما هو
ارهابي ولما هو غير ارهابي المشكله اننا
عندما نكون مختلفين بين بعضنا البعض نختلف
على كل القيم وعلى كل القواعد وهذا الذي
تماما يجعل من الجماعات ومن ومن ومن
منظمات الارهاب مساله نتنازع في فهمها بين
دوله واخرى شكرا لكما دكتور محمد قواص
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي في لندن واشكر في
واشنطن الدكتور جيمز كراف مدير معهد
الدراسات الدوليه في مؤسسه هريتج